this video is brought to you by
Squarespace the all-in-one platform
where entrepreneurs can easily create
and customize their own personal or
professional website more on Squarespace
later in the video so hello and welcome
to another episode of biographics I'm
your interim host Carl Smallwood and
today we're talking about James Madison
The Genius of politics and as with all
of our videos this one is based on an
original article by one of our lovely
authors at home and that author is Larry
holsworth if they provide a social media
links for us they'll be listed below
alongside my own but let's get to
it James Madison is often referred to as
the founder of the United States
Constitution a highly educated son of a
wealthy Virginia Family Madison studied
theology in college yet never entered
the clergy he studied law in Virginia
yet never practiced it he regarded
democracy as an unworkable form of
government yet argued for Democratic
representation of the people in Congress
of all the founds of the United States
he was probably the most knowledgeable
of the history and evolution of the
representative government he was a
master of political science before that
term even existed a walking
contradiction he was trained by a
clergyman but distrusted religion argued
for individual Freedom yet enslaved
hundreds on his Virginia estate simple
in appearance quiet and thoughtful he
married a woman who later in life would
be considered a celebrity he's often
called the father of the Bill of Rights
though it took considerable persuasion
by colleagues before he'd come to
recognize the need for one in a new
government when he did agree he was more
a matter of iCal expediency than
protecting personal freedoms he was
above all a politician of considerable
skill like most of America's slave
owning Founders he did not espouse the
equality of the races though he did
recognize the evils of slavery in his
later years he adopted the views of
transporting freed slaves to colonies
set aside specifically for them
supported financially by the societies
formed for that Express purpose to
Modern Eyes such views are racist yep
yet in his day they were alarmingly
daring and quite forward thinking he was
a product of his time who reshaped the
world and whose acts continue to rehap
the world to this very
day James Madison Jr was born on his
family's Plantation at belgrove Virginia
on March 16th 1751 he was the first of
what eventually became 12 children born
to James Madison Senior and Elanor
Conway Madison through whom he could
trace his maternal lineage to the
Brewsters and Allison families
descendants of the original Mayflower
pilgrims as a child he was known legally
as James Madison Junior there was often
called Jimmy a name he came to greatly
dislike in part because of his
diminutive size of his 11 siblings only
five survived into adulthood his early
childhood was spent at belgrove later
named Mont peler after the construction
of a large Plantation Home on the site
in his youth Bel grve was near the
Virginia Frontier and the fear of Indian
attacks was part and parcel of everyday
existence men went armed to the fields
and went about their business my 1760
the young Madison was acquainted with
Virginia militia Colonel George
Washington yes that George Washington
his neighbor Lord Fairfax and other
military and Civic leaders of the colony
his early schooling was mainly through
tutors chiefly Donald Robertson a
Scottish scholar at 17 Madison decided
not to attend College of William and
Mary then favored by Virginians for the
education of their sons his reticence
was attributed to the school's location
in Williamsburg which was viewed as
being unhealthy due to its proximity to
tital swamps and rivers instead bison
entered the College of New Jersey later
to become Princeton University Madison
studied the classical disciplines of
Greek Latin and theology as well as the
emerging philosophies of the
Enlightenment he read The Works of Isaac
Newton David Hume Jean Jac rouso Emanuel
K voler and many others that we all like
to name drop to sound smarter in
conversations in addition he also
studied the histories of tacitus
Josephus and other works of ancient
Antiquity one of his classmates and
friends was a young New Jersey native
named Aron Burr 3 years younger than
Madison the Virginia's mind and work
ethic was such that he completed the
prescribed 3ye curriculum for a Bachelor
of Arts degree in Just 2 years yet his
habits also brought about fits of
exhaustion leading to him developing a
reputation for being weak and sickly
following his 1771 graduation he elected
to remain at a college for a Time
learning to read and write in Hebrew
just for fun I suppose as well as
studying political philosophy under John
Witherspoon a presbyterian clergyman and
president of the College of New Jersey
his influence on young Madison was such
that James returned to his family's
Plantation in 1772 with the idea of
actually entering the clergy himself
self instead though he remained at his
family seat tutoring his younger
siblings in 1773 he began to read law
aided by a friend who recommended a
books for him to study though Madison is
frequently referred to as a lawyer he
never actually considered himself to be
one referring to his standing as a
student of the law only he never sought
admission to the bar or practiced law
professionally settle down class settle
down we'll just be taking a short break
from our presentation on James medison
to talk to you about the sponsor of
today's video Squarespace Squarespace is
the all-in-one website platform suitable
for anyone from amateurs to
professionals Squarespace makes it easy
for you to create a website that you can
use to promote yourself engage with your
audience and sell your products or
services and to all of you sitting here
who think you could do a better job than
me I'm looking at you Emily Squarespace
allows you to set up your own online
course all you need to do is pick up a
template that best fits your brand and
upload your lessons if you would like to
charge for your course you can choose
whether you would like to sell
subscriptions or offer your customers a
onetime fee once your course is set up
you can customize it in any way you like
using the say it with me class fluid
engine that's correct with fluid engine
you can add elements to your page just
by simply dragging and dropping them in
and then you can c customize them
however you like Squarespace tracks
everything from visitors to your site to
where your sales are coming from not
only does this allow you to monitor the
success of your course but you can also
use the data to figure out how to update
your website or your course for the
better check out squarespace.com
biographics for 10% off on your first
purchase of a website or domain using
the code
biographics right class break is over
back to the
presentation James Madison's studies as
well as the tutelage of John Witherspoon
led him to distrust the Anglican Church
which at the time exercised a
considerable legal Authority in Britain
and British North America in Virginia
for example attendance at weekly
Services was mandatory as was tithing
and other forms of financial support for
the Church Madison grew to oppose such
power in the church over matters which
he viewed as wholly secular in nature
during the years of the American
Revolution three distinct areas of
political alignment emerged between 20
and 33% of Americans were loyalists
loyalists remained aligned to the
British crown the Anglican church and
Parliament and specifically parliament's
right to in laws and taxes in the
colonies a roughly equal number of
Patriots opposed them arguing Parliament
and the church had exceeded their bounds
regarding rulle of the colonies a
significant number of American colonists
over onethird of their population
perhaps as much as half supported
neither side only a minority of American
population actually support the
revolution while perhaps more
importantly to the study of history the
majority did not Madison however did and
though he did not serve as a warrior his
role was in shaping the newly formed
government he served the 1776 Virginia
convention which created the first
constitution for the state of Virginia
in which he insisted on the legal
protections of religious freedoms he
then entered the newly created Virginia
House of delegates as a representative
he participated in debates over the
ratification of Articles of
Confederation ation in 1777 which he
opposed Madison found the Articles of
Confederation to be unworkable as the
basis for a national government under
the government established by the
Article of Confederation Madison was
elected to the Congress serving from
1780 to 1783 during that period a
largely powerless Congress dealt with
the ongoing War rampant inflation and
inability to impose taxes or tariffs and
other difficulties which his own bylaws
prevented it from resolving Congress
could enact no laws which weren't agreed
to by all 13 colonies crippling it for
all intents and purposes Madison
returned to the Virginia House of
delegates in 1784 where he ushered
through the legislature of the Virginia
statue for religious freedoms written by
Jefferson who was absent in Paris during
debates over it the landmark document
established the state religion in
Virginia and later served as a precursor
of The Establishment Clause of the
United States Constitution the weakness
of the federal government under the
Articles of Confederation led Madison to
urge that they be amended through a
convention attended by all the States
among his many concerns were the
benefits of representative democracy
over pure democracy and the need to
achieve equity in representation between
the larger and smaller states of the
Union James Madison was not a large man
he stood about 5' 4 in tall and weighed
just over1 at the time when the average
man stood about 5' 8 in and weighed
about £40 and this actually makes James
Madison the shortest man to serve as
president the Curious The Talk this was
Abraham Lincoln who stood at 6' 4 in
tall and the second place winner is
controversially Donald Trump who claims
to be 6' 3 in tall and weigh just £ 215
moving back to Madison he wasn't at all
sickly as he's often described in
reports from contemporaries and he
enjoyed robust Health very late into his
quite long life he was quite sensitive
regarding his size often enduring
insults from political enemies such as
sneering references to Little Jimmy he
did not possess a strong speaking voice
either and preferred not to engage
engage in vocal debate in public his
preference was to present his opinions
and arguments in writing he arrived at
the 1787 Convention to address the
Articles of Confederation with his
position well prepared Madison spent the
years between 1783 departure from
Congress and the 1787 Convention
studying the governments of republics
from history and soliciting input of
opinions from Thomas Jefferson Edmund
Randolph George Washington George Mason
and many others Jefferson himself was
not present at the Constitutional
Convention but his ideas were included
in 's document now known as the Virginia
plan although he authored the Virginia
Plan Madison chose not to present it to
the convention leaving that task to his
fellow Virginia delegate Edmund Randolph
Randolph at the time served the governor
of Virginia and Madison believed that he
would lend a greater gravitas to the
plan than he W with his less than
imposing stature The Plan called for
three separate branches of government an
executive a legislative and a Judicial
each serving to check the powers of the
others and thus establishing a balance
of power between the three he also
called for a bisaro legislature with one
body representing the people and the
other their respective states in the
debates that ensued over the plans and
the many many compromises which were
required in order to see its
recommendations enacted Madison remained
largely on the sidelines eventually the
Virginia Plan became the basis of the
federal government of the United States
that it was heavily heavily revised by
the delegates Madison opposed nearly all
of these changes as passed by the
Constitutional Convention only
representatives in the lower house of
Congress were to be elected directly by
the people senators were appointed by
the state legislators and the President
and Vice President were elected by
electors sitting in colleges
[Music]
assembled though today he's often called
the father of the Bill of Rights and
though he author the 10 amendments that
came to be known by that name Madison
initially opposed a Bill of Rights in
the Constitution at all his views were
that such rights were implied he also
believed that any rights not
specifically enumerated would thus be
denied when his colleague Virginia
delegate George Mason withdrew his
support for the Constitution unless a
Bill of Rights was added Madison was
reluctant to agree Mason's opposition to
the Constitution threatened its
ratification in Virginia and ended his
lifelong friendship with his neighbor
George Washington again yes that George
Washington yet it also Drew Madison's
attention who reasoned that since such
amendments were merely enumerated rights
already implied adding them to the
document would appease those in
opposition without undue harm Madison
wrote the first 12 amendments using
Mason's ideas 10 of which were ratified
as what is now known today as the Bill
of Rights an 11th dealing with the
manner in which Congress paid itself was
finally ratified in
1992 two centuries after Mason and
Madison initially suggested it I've
heard that the uh the gears of the
federal government grind slowly but
grind finally but that's taking the piss
Madison was not known as an enthusiastic
compromiser yet he compromised in order
to ensure ratification and the creation
of the new government Madison's support
of the constitution in letters that
became known as The Federalist Papers
did not include a Bill of Rights and he
even argued against one yet he gradually
came to change his mind persuaded in
some part by Jefferson and then Mason
but mainly by political expediency when
he ran for the new Congress against
James Monroe in 1788 Madison made
support for the Bill of Rights part of
his
platform while serving in the
Confederation Congress James Madison
then in his 20s resided in Philadelphia
Boarding House Madison favorite black
suits which made him appear as a
minister or even an Undertaker an
impression fortified by his reticence to
engage in Social niceties another
Philadelphia resident at the time
socialite Peggy shien who eventually
married Benedict Arnold yes that
Benedict Arnold wrote that there was and
I quote nothing engaging or even
bearable about Madison's manners he was
to shien again to quote a gloomy stiff
creature we try nonetheless James
pursued a young woman who resided in the
same boarding house Kitty Floyd the
16-year-old daughter of New York
delegate William Floyd by 1783 they had
agreed to marry during the summer of
1783 Floyd and his daughter returned to
New York accompanied by another Resident
at The Boarding House a medical student
named William Clarkson Madison spent
part of his Summit at Mont peler and
while there he wrote a letter to Thomas
Jefferson that Communications from his
betrothed had ceased marrison finally
received a letter from Kitty in August
and he was informed that she had
developed a preference for a young Mr
Clarkson and at the wedding was off
Madison was desolate and withdrew even
further from society not until 1793 did
Madison decide to once again dip his
toes into the dark sea that is romance
he was introduced to a young recently
widowed mother of two named Dolly pay
Todd by their mutual friend Aaron bur by
that point Madison was somewhat of a
local celebrity due to his efforts in
creating you know the Constitution he
was also quite Rich which I can't
imagine didn't help then a member of
Cong Congress Madison proposed marriage
after a few months they were married on
September 17th 1794 Madison was then 42
years of age 17 years older than his
bride they made their home in Mont peler
and rented rooms in Philadelphia
whenever Congress was in session his
much younger wife brought James bison
out the shadows in many social settings
where he mingled with members of the now
emerging political parties and
discovered the value of back runes in
cutting political deals her role within
government continued to expand over the
ensuing two decades when Thomas
Jefferson and into the presidency in
1801 the First Take Office in the new
federal city of Washington Madison was
appointed as Secretary of State Dolly
Madison became Washington's leading
Hostess the White House the capital and
the offices of government were all in
various stages of incompetence oh sorry
incompletion that wasn't a that was like
a genuine misreading of the um the
script streets were unpaved Meers in
rainy weather and roted dust tracks went
dry the state department was located in
a newly erected two-story building to
the west of the president's Mansion as
it was then called Madison State
Department shared its quarters with the
Navy Department the war department the
treasury the patent office and the post
office so quite crowded in this
incomplete city of an often malarial
climate Dolly Madison became the leader
of society she was often asked to serve
as the Widow Jefferson's Hostess for
Affairs at the president's mansions and
in their temporary residence on F Street
she held levies and receptions of her
own she hosted diplomats and their wise
members of the government visiting
dignitaries and leaders and developed an
international reputation as a gracious
and gifted host
in the minds of many such dignitaries
she out Shon her
husband in 1809 James Madison became the
fourth President of the United States
the third from Virginia and the first
who have previously served of the House
of Representatives he entered the White
House at a time of crisis with Great
Britain over trade rights Freedom of the
Seas and British transgressions on the
American fron here the Napoleonic Wars
in Europe in which the United States
remained strictly neutral damaged
American Trade the policies of his
predecessor Thomas Jefferson had
crippled American shipping through his
enforcement of an embargo over British
goods America was in no position to
assert its rights through Force the Navy
had been largely disbanded and its few
remaining ships remained idle in Port
the Army consisted of a few regiments
scattered throughout the frontier or
garring in unfinished ports along the
Eastern Seaboard on paper after
Jefferson's Louisiana Purchase the
United States stretched halfway across
the North American continent in practice
most of the West from Ohio to the
Mississippi River was disputed between
settlers and native tribes Madison had
supported the Louisiana Purchase as
Secretary of State as president he found
he lacked the means to actually enforce
it British possession and fors were
found throughout the lands purportedly
owned by the United
States during the first two years of his
administration James Madison was forced
to contend with depredations by both the
British and the French British ships
stopped American vessels on the high
seas seizing Sailors they claimed were
British citizens and conscripting them
forcibly into service in the Royal Navy
meanwhile French privateers and Naval
vessels just attacked American ships
claiming they were trading with Nations
at war with France a direct violation of
Napoleon's continental system in the
United States two factions emerged one
demanding war with Britain the other a
war with France a tough choice those
demanding war with Britain led by Henry
Clay of Kentucky and John C Calhoun of
South Carolina became known as the
warhawks which admit Le is kind of rad
the warhawks also coveted Canada
believing it could be taken from the
British n shorts military campaign they
believe the Canadians would welcome the
opportunity to become Americans free of
British
rule like spoilers Canadians still have
the like the queen on their money in
June 1812 the warhawks achieved a
majority in Congress and James Madison
became the first American President to
request Congress to declare war Madison
informed the house that the nation could
no longer tolerate what was and I quote
deao state of war against the United
States by Britain Madison thus became
America's first war time president and
would in the course of the war become
the first sitting president to observe
American troops in battle in many ways
the war was a disaster for Americans the
Canadians demonstrated a decided Reserve
at becoming Americans siding for the
most part with the British the nation's
capital including the president's house
the capital building and the officers of
the government were burned by the war's
end America's tiny Navy was mostly
bowled up in ports yet there were some
successes minor successes but successes
nonetheless America for example
controlled the Great Lakes by the war's
end the threat from Britain's Indian
allies was mostly neutralized and Andrew
Jackson's stirring victory over British
Invasion forces in Louisiana and Alabama
restored national pride the contending
sides accepted the war's end as a and I
quote status quo antibellum in essence a
draw Madison's presidency which saw
several inrs be made towards further
strengthening the federal government is
irretrievably linked to the war of 182
yet he left behind a government that
continued to maintain a standing Army
and Navy and reestablished a national
bank and system of Taxation to support
it he also helped shape the role of the
Federal Government in completing
internal improvements which as roads
canals and ports to stimulate the
nation's economic and Commercial
growth James manison retired from
political life after the completion of
his second term as president in 1817
like Washington and Jefferson before him
he left office a considerably less
wealthy man than he had been when he
entered it rebuilding his wealth proved
elusive he was hampered by poor harvest
of his main crops wheat and flax and
depressed prices at Market he was also
burdened with debts not of his own
making you see while James bison had no
children of his own Dolly's two children
were raised by him in his household and
in particular her son John Payne Todd
was asked to manage his mon pellier
estate when Madison had been in office
Todd was not very good at this and ran
up considerable debts against the estate
deaths caused by inattention to his
duties and a pension for drinking
gambling and collecting race horses in
retirement Madison struggled to pay off
these debts like many of America's
Founders Madison was raised in a system
which relied heavily on the labor of
enslaved peoples his W Pelle state for
example including slave laborers which
numbered more than a 100 at times in
retirement Madison did support the
creation of societies which attempted to
set up colonies for freed slaves yet he
did not free his own not even upon his
death in his will he actually left his
slaves to Dolly with the instructions
that they could neither be sold nor
emancipated without their consent there
were instructions that Dolly soundly
ignored Madison's Mont state became a
Haven for guests and relatives in his
later years always depicted a stiff and
informal person Madison was actually
very much the opposite at home going as
far as to participate in piggyback races
on his plantations launs with the former
president born on the back of his wife
which so I guess being small had its
benefits his health remained with him
until very near the end he occupied his
time by writing and rewriting his
collections of the debates during the
Constitutional conventions believing
that Dolly could publish them after his
death he also served as a second Rector
of the University of Virginia replacing
its founder Thomas Jefferson in
1826 he died at Mont peler in June 28th
1836 from the effects of liver disease
tradition has him dying quietly while
dining at breakfast he was buried at his
Estates the following year an
impoverished Dolly moved to Washington
where she resided until her death having
being forced to sell the estate and its
enslaved peoples to satisfy her deaths
she died in 1849 after internment at the
Congressional ceremony in Washington she
was exhumed and buried next to her
husband at the grounds of their former
home Madison is known to American
history as the father of the
Constitution and of the Bill of Rights
neither is wholly accurate perhaps his
greatest Legacy is one that's often
forgotten yet still Germain in his essay
number 10 part of the Federalist Papers
Madison described what he called the
tyranny of the majority and the
Democracy as well as the duty of an
elected government to protect and defend
the rights of the minority That Remains
the essence of the American Republic and
a source of heated debate in American
life in a land where the the majority
doesn't always ruin so thank you for
tuning in to this episode of biographics
as mentioned at the start I've been your
interim host KL Smallwood yes that is my
real name and this video is based on
original article submitted by the writer
Larry holsworth so if they provided
social media links for you there will be
link below alongside my own thank you
for tuning in if you enjoyed the video
leave a like if you got any comments to
say about it leave them Below in the
comment section in particular I'd like
to ask people to leave feedback about my
presentation and hosting style I'm
trying to find something that is a a
good fit for the um the topics and uh
like you know established style and
voice of this channel as um uh let you
know refined to I'm going to say to a
mirror Sheen by my esteemed colleague
Simon Whistler who I'm happy to call AIA
and you know some I wrote a lot of
articles for back in the day for top 10s
which is a sister site to um biographics
as well as today I found out yeah I'm
trying to find my own voice and style so
any feedback about that let me know
otherwise if you want to see more videos
like this sub subscribe and as always
have the day you all deserve
cheers